My audience asked me questions for 10
hours and here are the best moments.
Let's say my only goal was just to get
rich AF.
What is rich AF? Just so we define it.
100 million. Why not? It's a good
number.
Cool.
You're willing to work hard but you have
limited skills and experience. What
business would you start like right now
2023?
And I have no money, right? I would
probably build a boring business in
services and I would probably pick
something around the body. you know, if
I wouldn't just start a design firm
because I think that has a high
likelihood of getting disrupted or, you
know, in some way by AI, if I were, you
know, as silly as this sounds, like a
nail salon or a lawn care service,
things that I mean, especially body
ones, uh, dentist stuff, like you you
still have to go in and get your teeth
taken care of. And many times people
value the human exchange more than
something robotic. So, for example, in
the fitness world, like this is my like
my data point around this. Uh there was
a a brand called Coco Fit and um they
struggled a ton and then eventually went
out of business because they tried to
automate personal training. So, they
created these all-in-one machines that
would you'd have a key fob and it would
count your reps and every time you went
to the machine it would say how to do
more and what weight you did last time.
It's a really cool concept. The problem
was their theory was that the reason
that people weren't getting results is
that they didn't know what to do when
the reality is that no one was showing
to the gym. People hire personal
trainers because they want another human
to talk to and to hold them accountable
to showing up. Same reason like if you
had a robot cutting hair, there might be
a percentage of the population that do
it, but a lot of women like the going to
the hair salon and having that exchange.
And so I would probably build a business
around services in general um would be
my way and then I would continue to
scale that. And you could do that at a
local chain level and you can make a lot
of money doing that or you could do it
at a national level which would be like
professional services.
I love the idea behind the core stuff
that's going to be here forever. You
know, let's say hypothetically the great
fires of Las Vegas burn everything to
the ground. Okay, you lost everything.
You had to start again. What would you
say is the number one thing that you
would have done differently to get to
where you are now?
And I have no reputation, right?
No, no reputation.
Yeah, it burns my reputation on the
ground with it. So, I actually have lost
everything before. Uh, and so I I know
what I did and I probably would have
done the same thing. So the the the
easiest way that I did to like go make a
h 100red grand in a month when I had
nothing uh was that I would go find a
business that was local that I
understood and that I could sell
something expensive for. I would front
the capital to market. I would work the
leads and I would sit at the front desk
and sell and I would negotiate what they
would be willing to do a a big bulk of
services at scale for. So, for example,
if I wanted to find a chiropractor and
I'd say, "Hey, if if I sent you 100
customers this month, what's the lowest
rate you would do all 100 customers for
this level of service?" And then I would
just negotiate that down. And then I
would spend as much as I could and sell
it for as much as I can so I could make
the spread and then they would service
the customers. And for them, it's a
zero- risk offer because they don't have
to do anything. I front everything else.
And then for me, I don't have to do
anything but market and sell and I can
take all of that. And so like when I
lost everything, I immediately was able
to make 100 grand the next month by
doing that playbook.
In your opinion, what are the three most
powerful skills that someone should
develop if they want to make a lot of
money?
I mean, the three core skills are you
got to learn how to build, you got to
learn how to sell, and you got to learn
how to lead.
Just like that. There we go. Like in in
terms of maybe like hard skills that
someone should really focus on learning
to develop that like sales,
copyrightiting, leadership, what would
you say are the most important?
Well, those are the three big buckets,
right? So it's like one is that like
leadership is just the internal bucket
of getting people to do what you want
them to do at scale right and then from
a selling perspective I include that in
all things that are marketing letting
people know about your stuff promotion
uh and actually converting people into
customers and then the third piece of
building product and services is so that
at scale if the product is good enough
[snorts] then you won't lose customers
and if it's exceptional the product
itself will get you more customers and
so most businesses take to their natural
extreme on a promotional level typically
are leaky buckets because the product
actually sucks and most businesses suck
in general because most products aren't
good and most people want to cancel very
quickly and don't want to continue to
use them which is why very very good
companies are very rare uh most of them
generally are mediocre or not good and
so I prefer to solve a business from
back to front which is like can we find
something that people actually like and
want to continue to use and continue to
pay for and then the marketing is almost
a commoditized skill like it's very easy
to let other people know about your
stuff and do so louder and louder and
louder provided the product is good. And
then the internal has to get run with a
leader that can attract the talent to
continue to do this because quickly the
the business will bottleneck based on
the founder and their expertise or
usually they have a niche. They might be
product people, they might be tech
people, they might be finance people,
they might be whatever. Um, and then
they have to be of the character to
attract the talent that will allow them
to get to, you know, nine figures or
whatever it is that their the goal is.
You mentioned on a recent podcast with
Tom Billu, uh, that you don't have
rules. So,
yeah,
I, for example, you know, I quite often
end up waking up until midnight, 2 a.m.,
3:00 a.m. and basically [__] up my
sleep schedule because I have too much
freedom, right? Because I'm
self-employed. So, how do you kind of
strike that balance between freedom and
discipline? You know, if you're driven
and you want to accomplish big things,
it's it's it's kind of 8020. Like, if
you know that when you stay up late,
like there are times when I will gas it
and go past my red line in terms of work
and I know that I'm eating into
tomorrow. But if I'm like in a flow and
I'm crushing it and the muse shows up
and the muse wants to work, then I work.
You know what I mean? But if there's
some days on the flip side where I wake
up and I just feel foggy as [__] and I
just like for whatever reason I ate too
much Mexican last night and my, you
know, I I just I don't have it that day,
then I I might call it earlier. Like the
idea of me pushing through and punishing
when it comes to the type of work I do.
If I were doing a more uh brute force
work, then I would care less. You know
what I mean? If it was just like if I
was just doing reachouts, I was doing
cold calls, I was training personal
training sessions, I was cutting hair,
I'm just I'm just going to brute force
my way through it because I don't need
to have higher brain function. And
that's not an insult. I'm just saying
like you're not like thinking of
creative things. You know what I mean?
You're just you're working the work. Um,
but when it comes to like writing or or
making presentations or communication of
some sort, it's more I try and optimize
around how can I maximize over a week
how much flow state I can be in so I can
just get the most total quality output.
So, it's not about rules. It's more like
which of these things has the highest
likelihood of getting me the most.
What's up, Kristoff?
In one podcast, you said that your most
feared decision in life was to quit your
job when you were 22 or 23. My question
is, what advice would you give to your
younger self if you could in that exact
situation?
When you have nothing to lose, it also
makes it the best time to make
high-risisk decisions because you have a
disproportionate upside. Not quitting if
you want to do something else, like if
you have this desire to do something
else, is like not taking a stranger up
on a free lottery ticket on the street.
If they give you a free lottery ticket
and you lose, you're back to not having
anything. If you win, then your life
changes forever. And so, I think a lot
of people place a disproportionate
amount of weight on the opinions of
other people who are going to judge them
in the short term because quitting your
job is short-term pain for long-term
fulfillment if that's what if that's
what you want to pursue. Because the
short-term pain comes from the judgment
of others and likely a back, you know, a
back step in income, but long term,
you're working on the thing that you
want to be working on. Now, if you like
your job and you know what I mean, then
that probably doesn't apply to those
people. But like, if you're in that
situation, it's really a long-term
short-term sacrifice, which a lot of
people aren't able to make.
The second question, let's think that my
audience uh don't know anything about
Laya except that she's your partner.
Okay.
But I think she's she has exceptional
knowledge and she she's a really good
personality. If you could only tell one
story about her that makes a complete
picture about her,
what would it what would it be? So Ila
had quit her job to join me to start gym
launch. This is when we were doing
turnarounds. So we're flying around the
country. So she quit her job after
knowing me for only a month and then
started basically living with me in
motel rooms. She had built up a book of
business. So she was actually giving up
something that she had spent 2 years
building to pursue this thing with me
and we were new like we had just started
dating. About 6 months into that I told
her that I needed a break. And the she
actually asked me she was like it sounds
like you don't really want me to be
here. Do you want me to leave? And I was
like, "Yes, that would be great." I had
just lost all the money from the
partner. I had this location that I had
to either shut down and had no cash to
do it and I had to service all these
contracts I didn't have the money to to
service. And I also had like three other
businesses that I was trying to run at
the same time. I had a chiropractor
agency. I had my gyms. I had Jim launch
the turnaround business. I had a dental
agency. All of those with different
partners. And I was the one who did
marketing sales for all of it. And so I
was just so spread thin. And so she I
needed to generate money uh to basically
pay the bills of the gym that I couldn't
pay that the money had just gone out the
door for right after me saying I don't
think we should be together. She had to
leave like the next day to go to Hawaii
to launch a gym for this guy that she's
no longer dating that she quit
everything to leave. Tough situation
that nine out of 10 not even nine 99 out
of 100 girls would have just said no.
They would have been like I'm just going
to go back home and you know try and get
all my clients back. But she didn't do
that. So she flew out to Hawaii. I
didn't have enough money to give her
like a nice place and so um I had her
split an Airbnb with five guys, five
dudes and Ila. Not ideal. And so she
worked out of the Airbnb and well
realistically she worked out of the gym
most of the time and did the biggest
launch that we'd ever done. And so like
when my world was crumbling around me
and I really needed her to come through,
she stood tall and she did it in a time
that I probably didn't deserve that
level of loyalty cuz I hadn't shown her
any. And so she did that and then I made
enough money from her launching that gym
that I could pay off all the bills of
the gym that was going under that I just
lost all the money on uh to basically
come out breaking even um so that we
could actually go back allin on gym
launch and get rid of the other
companies.
Oh man, I think I haven't heard this
story before. What what went through
through your mind? I I can't really
believe this and understand it.
Well, when she did that, I wanted to be
with her. She had extended me loyalty
that I had not given her. There was
probably a few defining moments in our
relationship. That was the first big
one.
Thank you very much for sharing this.
The next one is kind of basic question,
but I'm really curious about the answer.
What was your biggest takeaway of
writing 100 million offers and also 100
million leads.
The offer is a strategic question that
influences all aspects of the business
and is also a mental exercise that
people can feel like they're making
progress on their offer a lot faster.
leads is a lot more about activity and
implementation. And so people can get
ideas from like the lead magnet chapter,
but then you have to start reaching out
to people, posting content, or running
ads to start getting leads in the door,
right? And so there's a little bit
bigger of a hurdle with leads than there
is offers, but it's also the the main
driver of business is letting people
know about your stuff. And so I think
that many people will mentally
masturbate to the idea of making these
amazing offers, but I think far more
people make money by actually letting
people know about their stuff, which is
leads.
What went through went through your mind
when when you rewrote it for the 18th or
19th time?
So unless I can work once and have
something provide value on an ongoing
basis, which is a high leverage
activity, um then it makes no sense. So
I think most people shouldn't write
books because the amount of work it
takes to make a great book that actually
lasts the test of time is extremely
difficult.
I think I I uh read a blog post where
they said uh how to write a blogbuster
blog post and there was a chart where
they said if you put in like a 100 hours
to write only one blog post there maybe
will be a million views but if you put
like 50 hours there maybe will be just
10,000 views. It's exactly that there's
diminishing marginal return but an
increase an exponential increase in
absolute returns. You know the gold the
gold medal sprinter in the Olympics
versus the silver medalist. Like from a
business context the person who's at the
gold medalist might have worked 10 times
more right to get this much more out.
But what's the difference in absolute of
gold versus silver? Everything. Just
being this much better. People are like
well I don't want to work 50 more hours
to be this much better. But being this
much better might make you the best at
that whatever the blog post is or that
business or that solution. And the
amount of winner takes all the economy
has shifted towards. People want the
lowest risk solution. And so if you have
the best solution, then it is the lowest
risk thing to buy. And so to be number
one versus number two, 80% of the
economics, sometimes 90% of the
economics go to number one. And so it
makes absolute sense to work 10 times
harder even though you might only be
this much better from a marginal
perspective on the chart of rankings
that might make you 10 times higher.
Some context we have like a book summary
application where we give also exercises
and tips to implement the book. What's
your average take on on books and uh I
mean book summaries? Is it good? Did you
use them before?
I don't read many book summaries. uh
mostly because you rely on the person
who's doing the summarizing to find what
they think is the most valuable thing
for you, right? Because a lot of times
what I find if I read a book, the the
nuggets that I find are not the main
concepts. It's actually the details. If
you don't know anything about a topic,
then summaries are great to give you a
lattice work, a framework to understand
the rest of the information that you're
going to consume. But once you have a
basic understanding, it's in the edges,
which is where you can expand your
knowledge, right? And so there's there's
not a lot of shortcuts to getting really
good at something.
Now, a bit of selfish question, but I'm
really curious about your thinking.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. So, you remember you
had a video where you scaled a no strip
business to 50 million in six minutes.
Could you do this with a book summary
app?
Basically do a breakdown of a book sum.
So, it's an application.
Yeah, it's a it's a subscription based
application.
Yeah. Got it. What's the price point?
Uh $10.
Okay. What's What's churn?
I think 15 to 20%.
Monthly or yearly?
Monthly.
Monthly. Got it. Um so, you have to fix
that first. At the end of the day,
everything's going to be cact. So like
if there was one single metric that I'm
going to look at a business, it's capped
LTV ratio. So how much it cost me to get
somebody and how much do I make from
them over the lifetime until that metric
is better than the competition. So like
Blinkist, right? I think that's a one
that's like that. I would have to look
at their LTV and what are the things
that they're doing that like why am I
why are people going to come to me
versus them, right? So either I have to
be more niche in my selection of books
so that I'll have a wider selection for
a narrower audience. like competing
against Amazon's very tough. But if you
if you if you niche down into a specific
topic, then you can actually have a
wider selection because Blinkist is just
going to take the the best sellers,
right, for every every category because
that's going to be the the most people
and they're VC backed and they're funded
and they can acquire customers at a loss
for a long period of time, acquire
market share. And unless that's the game
you're trying to play, then you have to
play it different, which is I want to I
want to be really specific about the
avatar that I want to go after. And so
that's where you do a little bit of
research ahead of time and say, "Okay,
is there an underserved market that
might actually a have a big reading
preference?" So like sales people is one
of the most common professions on planet
Earth from a personality perspective.
How many sales guys read all the time? I
don't know. I would have to I would have
to look into that. And so you might be
like, "Okay, well sales guys aren't the
guy, but maybe HR specialists read a
ton." Okay. Well, if they read a ton and
there's like Blinkist might have one
book on HR, but I could put a hundred
different things that are related to
that or one degree separated and then I
can create the illusion of a wider
selection of topics but around a
narrower a narrower avatar or concept,
right? I would start there and then over
time you can expand if you if you want
to and just reach, you know, you go
adjacent, you go to finance or you go to
whatever. Like this is me just
spitballing again like I did the no
strip thing. From the the economics
perspective, you have to get LTV to the
point where like your churn should be
under 3%.
In order to make this really work once
it's under 3% monthly. Yeah.
Monthly.
Monthly. I mean, ideally, you want to
maintain 80% annually at least. If you
want this thing to be a big thing, all
of my attention would be only focused on
that. Like until you fix that, there's
no point in acquiring customers cuz
they're just going to fall out the back
end. Like there's literally no point cuz
then you're also getting lots of people
in that will then say that that thing
sucks. You know what I I'm not saying it
sucks, but I'm just saying like they're
they're a friend of theirs is gonna say,
"Hey, I signed up for this thing."
They're gonna be like, "Oh, I tried it.
I didn't like it." And then they're
like, "Oh, okay. Maybe I won't I won't
stick on it." I want to be so quiet
about what I'm building until all my
metrics are right, and then I want to
blow the the doors off. But most people
want to keep hitting these income goals
rather than looking at the the metrics
of the business that are actually going
to drive the long-term goal. Cuz like
anyone can market their way to a 100,000
or a million a month even with an app
like this. If you blow enough money,
enough people find out about you can do
it. But then you can only maintain it as
long as you're spending that much money.
The moment you your your spend drops,
your income drops. And that's not a
business that I want to be a part of.
Our uh USP is that we are doing we are
we are in Hungary and we are doing it in
Hungarian and there is no other
application in Hungary.
Okay, that's great.
If we scale to maybe Poland, we would do
it in Polish and not in English. And
that's a USP.
I like that. And I mean then at that
point I would just look at I I try and
model as closely as I possibly can the
number one player in the US from a UX
perspective from the selection of titles
all that kind of stuff. And then I would
and I would see if my metrics change if
I do that. If not then it's like there's
some assumption that I'm basing this
business off of that's not right.
In the Denny Miranda podcast I think you
talked about skills versus meta skills.
Could you expand this maybe?
Uh a meta skill is a skill that helps
you acquire more skills. Learning how to
read is a meta skill. Like learn like
learning how to learn is a meta skill at
at at the with the broadest brushstroke
the all the way chunked up learning to
learn well quickly and retain
information and be able to implement it
is is a skill. You give a 100 people a
course right that's free. The difference
between the people who are going to be
successful and not successful are the
ones who already have sufficient meta
skills to be able to then use the
information and implement it. Like at at
one polar extreme you've got somebody
who's completely incompetent, right? who
like you have to teach them how to turn
on a computer and on the other extreme I
can say go build me a company and the
person can do it. So this person can
translate a directive into each of the
subbuckets and knows how to do that and
so it's really like your success
percentage basically is predetermined by
how low you break down the skill
requirements for someone to be
successful. So like the reason that I
write the books at the grade level that
I do isn't so that people who are
experts don't get value from it. is so
that it makes it even easier for experts
and it makes it attainable for people
who don't know. So I can get 70% of
people who read the book to get leads
versus 10% of people to get leads if I
just cut out some of the steps and made
assumptions about their skill level. The
last 10 or 20% the people who are
experts are still going to benefit from.
I'm just also going to include turn on
your computer. Here's how you do that.
And from the software perspective with
what you're doing, that's also how you
get a way larger percentage of your
clients to activate. Typically, we make
assumptions because we assume that every
customer is just like us. And so, they
have the same meta skills as us and they
have the same inter interpretation or
perception of the world and the UX. And
so, that that assumption isn't true.
Like, all you have to do is, and I'm
sure you've done this, like you look at
people scrolling on your app and you see
the heat maps and you're like, why are
they clicking that button? Because they
have different skills and experiences
that they're bringing to the table. And
so, then you just continue to
accommodate it. Break it down to the
level that you could show it to a
three-year-old and they would
immediately know how to use it. Like the
fact that babies learn how to use iPods
is an indication of how how simple they
have made it to humans to use and that's
why they have such mass adoption.
How would you teach someone how to
learn?
We already know how to learn. It's just
that most people don't know how to
teach. Everybody learns stuff all the
time, right? If I if you touch a stove
and it's hot and it's and it and it
burns you, you learn not to do it again.
Like learning is is natural. like we all
learn, but people who want to teach a
specific behavior don't know how to do
it. And so it really just comes down to
three things, which is what do I reward?
What do I punish? And what do I
extinguish, right? So reward is you give
a carrot right after someone does
something. Punish is you, you know, you
zap them or you smack them after they do
something. Or extinguish is you do
nothing. Right? So if your wife walks in
and she got her her nails painted neon
orange and you don't like it, you might
not want to punish her because that's
probably going to have negative
ramifications in the rest of your life.
But you might extinguish it. So you
might not say anything about the nails
or you might say something different.
She's like do you like my nails? I might
say something back like I'm I'm happy
that you got what you want. What we're
doing is what behavior are we training?
And so if you think about learn teaching
as training I think it's a much more
useful word to think through because at
the end of the day you have only taught
someone if their behavior changes in the
same context. As in, if I want you to
say these words when the phone rings, if
I say, "Cool, we're going to put you
through this training and then the phone
rings and then you don't say the words,
you have not learned and I have not
taught you." And so it's how many times
can I simulate this experience, this
stimulus, the context, so that I can
have them do the behavior I want within
the context that's going to trigger it
and then reward them immediately. And
that's how you have a feedback loop that
trains people to do something. So that
is why the streaks in the application
and the gamification and those stuff.
How would you restructure the education
system if you could?
Yeah. Sorry for this question.
No, you're good. You're good. I would
focus almost exclusively on meta skills.
Teaching people how to learn step one
and then teaching people the things that
are the next level underneath which is
learning how to write, learning how to
read, learning how to speak, learning
how to do math. Like those are the those
are the building blocks of everything
else that follows. And in the school of
the school of Alex or the school of
Hormosi, everyone passes only when you
learn. There are only 100%s and you
continue to do it until you learn. I
like the arbitrary division of grades
along age is ridiculous to me. And I
think that if there were a lot more
clarity around the goal, which is like
until you can read 10 pages out loud
without making a mistake, you do not
move on. If you can do that in a day,
fantastic. If you can if it takes you a
year, okay, I don't judge you on that.
It's just how long will it take you to
learn the skill? So, a good buddy of
mine, Dr. Cashy, taught an autistic kid
how to read. He couldn't stay still
reading uh for more than one word at a
time and then he would like have fits or
whatever. And so, he came to train the
child on how to read with a bag of
Skittles. And so, when the kid would
read a word, he would give them a
Skittle. When he would read more words
in a row than he ever had, like a
record, he would give him two Skittles.
So, he rewarded the behavior. And then
he had big bonus rewards when he would
achie unlock a new level. And so he kept
doing that and within one afternoon he
had him reading a full page. What is the
behavior that I want to reward? How can
I reward more of it? Now none of it was
punishing. He didn't smack him when he
messed up. When he read less, he still
gave him one to reward him for the
activity. And then when he read more, he
gave him extra reward. As the kid
becomes less full on Skittles and he's
like, you know, sugar, he like doesn't
want any skills anymore. The Skittles
become a proxy for approval and they
work just the same. How do you know that
when to when to punish, when to reward
or when to extinguish?
We try very hard to almost exclusively
reward because punishment changes
behavior faster. Reward changes behavior
behavior longer. It just takes longer to
work, right? Like if if someone, you
know, calls me Alex and I don't like
that and I slap them and I say, "Never
call me that again." I might change
their behavior really quickly. If I
leave the room and someone else says
walks in, they might say I was talking
to Alex because I'm not there to punish
them. And so punishment only works as
long as the the source of punishment is
there and the person doesn't get
accustomed to the punishment because
punishment itself becomes desensitized
over time. And so to effectively punish
someone, if you want to consistently
punish, then you have to increase the
intensity and variety of punishment over
time because otherwise people get
desensitized to it. If you're always
mean and yell at all of your employees,
eventually they stop caring. So you have
to increase the level of your threats,
right? You then have to say, "I'm going
to fire you. I'm going to kill you."
Right? You have to make these threats
increase because you create the you
increase the intensity and the variety
of how you claim to punish them. Reward,
you can reward long enough that you can
then extend the gaps between reward to
eventually you don't need a reward
anymore and people will continue to do
the activity because they have always
done it.
So it's the exact uh example with Dr.
Cesy and the guy.
Yeah, I would imagine if he was doing
this over and over again, he'd proved
the point. I don't he's not like a
full-time reading teacher. The concept
is that he would read and then maybe the
next time he comes in he gives him a
Skittle every other time he reads and
then the next time every third time and
the next time only when he when he hits
a new record. If I can get the kid to
read long enough that he actually starts
to like the story then the story starts
to reward in and of itself and then I
can move away and then the kid reads
without me. And so fundamentally that's
what you try to do when you train any
activity is that most people who are
experts at anything get rewarded from
the activity itself because once you
develop a level of mastery in the skill
you enjoy it because you're good at it.
So we hope I hope we will meet again and
maybe speak longer. Thank you very much
dude. I appreciate you Kristoff. Thank
you so much. Thank you for inviting your
community and hopefully your community
got value from the event. Um and
hopefully they use the books and and
grow the economy in Hungary and uh and
all get, you know, way way better at
whatever it is they're doing. You are
[snorts] incredibly committed to
education and self-improvement.
How do you select what you will pursue
for education? There's so many possible
topics. Uh so what process do you go
through to select uh what you're going
to be educating yourself on and how do
you also select potentially someone to
educate you on that topic?
We do everything off the theory
constraints at acquisition.com which is
basically that a system will grow until
its constraint until its limit. So it's
kind of like the idea of the the weakest
link, right? So it's it's finding what
the weakest link in the chain is where
the constraint of the system is so that
we can deconstrain it and then grow to
the next natural constraint. It's a very
simplistic look, but it's extremely
effective because it just cuts down all
the noise into like if I had to pick one
thing that is the big limitation of this
business, what would it be? And so then
we just get laser laser focused on
solving that one problem. Solve that
problem and then we move on to the next
constraint. And if we solve that problem
and the business doesn't grow, well then
we pick the wrong constraint. And so
sometimes the constraint is your ability
to judge what the constraint is which is
why you know wisdom is one of the
hardest things to earn which comes from
experience right is that you're able to
you know recognize patterns. Um and so
for me right now uh to answer the the
other part of the question I'm focused
on um learning about brand stuff right
now. So brand is my big topic that I've
been diving really deep on brand and
media and I'll probably write a book on
brand just from the findings that I have
because I don't think there's many good
books on brand because you can I could
read you 20 different definitions of
brand and branding and they all sound
like cockamy and so coming up with an
operationalized version of what that
means so that it can actually be useful
and I I I try to learn the stuff so that
I can use it and then whatever I learn I
just you know pass it forward because
branding for me despite being now quote
known for this or like an organic
content guy. I've only been doing this
two years. Like this is brand new to me.
Like I, you know, I have way more
experience on the paid ad side. That's
what I did for the last decade. And I,
you know, people got to see a tiny taste
of that when I was launching the book.
But that's that's the big thing is
finding out what the constraint of the
business is. And if you need to chunk
all the way up, it's if you want to grow
a business, you have to sell more
clients or make them worth more or
decrease risk. Those are the those are
the things that are going to grow the
value of a company. And so just simply
asking the question like why do we not
have 10 times more customers or why are
we not making 10 times more money and
then figuring out what the answer to
that question is often times is the
constraint.
Just because you're saying hey I'm I'm
currently educating myself on on
branding and that's fresh for you. What
would you say is like a major takeaway
in terms of education for the topic of
branding that you're just like I wish I
would have maybe known this when I
started to try to learn about this two
years ago.
This is like a Pandora's box. If I start
talking about it it might be like 10
minutes. So I I can I can riff on it but
like buckle in the audience. So if we
look at the origins of what a brand is,
right? Where do brands come from? Brand
comes when you brand cattle, right? That
was the original use of a brand. And so
why would you brand cattle? Because you
want to change the behavior of people
who look at the cattle. So if you have a
cattle that doesn't have a brand and the
cattle that does, the people who are
looking at it will behave differently.
If the c the cow doesn't have a brand, I
might take the cow for myself or I might
kill it or I might eat it. I might do
whatever. But if the cow has a brand on
it and I know the guy, I might return
the cow to him. Right? So it changes
what I do. All right, that's important
point. So the point of a brand is to
change or elicit a desired behavior in
the widest percentage of your target
audience. All right. Now, how do you do
that? You do that by making associations
between something they don't know, your
brand in the beginning, with something
that they do know that is positive and
rewarding if that's what you want,
right? And so the index, it's a 4x4 uh
box of what brand really is. you have
the uh the the direction. So you've got
away from and towards and then you've
got strength. So very high and very low.
So you know if you have a really weak
thing that's away from it's like I kind
of don't like this thing you know slow
Wi-Fi you know like bad brand. On the
flip side you might have a political
party which depending on the audience
might be super strong and away from or
towards. Now, Taylor Swift, for example,
would be someone that I would say has a
very strong brand and towards there's
not a lot of people who really hate
Taylor Swift. Um, and a lot of people
who really love Taylor Swift, right? So,
it's positive and it's strong, right?
Somebody like Ray Romano, if you heard
that, you know, or like Tim Allen from
the old sitcom days, might be someone
who is positive but weak. A lot of
people know who he is. Am I going to
show up to his event? Probably not. The
idea is that in order to build a brand,
we simply pair things that people know
with things that they don't know. The
things they don't know is our logo, our
tagline, our company with things that
they do know and think are positive. If
you were to think about the brand as a
bouquet of flowers, it's like having
many flowers in a bouquet. And so if I
were to break the bouquet and spread all
the flowers, there is no bouquet. But
simply by gathering them together, by
making associations, I create something
new. And that bundle of associations is
the brand. Now, if I were to break one
of the flowers or make it rotten, it
would affect the appearance of the
entire brand. And so that's why if you
make a single mistake, a Dylan Mulaney
move for Bud Light, you can affect the
entire brand. If I get a DUI or somebody
you know gets, you know, accused of
doing some sort of terrible heinous act,
right, it affects the entire brand. R.
Kelly, bad brand now, right? Despite all
the positive, the one broken rose or the
one rotten flower affects the entire
bouquet. We have to be very deliberate
about what associations we want to make
with our own brand so that we can
continue to positively associate
ourselves. And the point of the brand is
that we get a desired action or behavior
from a specific audience. The idea of
growing the brand a lot of times is that
you sacrifice some audience for other
audiences. So like when I was starting
making content, I did it in my closet,
right? Right. And there were some
hardcore people in the OG Mosy Media
days that are like, I appreciate you.
That were like, man, I missed the closet
videos. Right now, I might have lost
some of those people when we started
making a little bit more polished
videos, etc. Some people, not all of
them. Right? I traded some I traded
losing some audience to gain more. When
you're making a brand move, you're
basically always making a bet that you
will gain more of your desired audience
than you lose by making a change. And so
you can approximate or slowly move a
brand over time by making more
associations in one direction and fewer
associations in the other. And so that's
how you can move a brand over time. Bud
Light made a wrong bet. They thought,
and maybe this is just corporate group
think, right? That if they made an
association Mulaney that they were going
to get more people to buy their beer.
That was I mean fundamentally that's the
only reason you would do it as a
company, right? You'd believe that
long-term you get more people to buy
your beer. The problem was that wasn't
true. Now the interesting thing is that
there probably are people who were a big
fan of that move. It's just that there
were more people who weren't.
They were far away,
right? There were more people who were
not a fan of that move and so that
became an away from association. And so
that is what I am trying to encapsulate
and put together um into how to brand.
Uh because now that I feel like I
understand it a little bit, I see it as
in my opinion, you know, it's kind of
like Neo in the Matrix when he's talking
to Morpheus and he says, "So you're
telling me that I can dodge bullets?"
Morpheus says, "Well, when you're ready,
you won't have to." And so we learn all
these tactics about sales and marketing
and show up rates and CRO hacks and all
this [__] But if you have a brand, if
you see the matrix, everyone shows up to
your calls. No one has price objections.
everyone is excited and refers their
friends. It just takes longer to make
associations because fundamentally all
branding is is teaching. You were
teaching someone to do something. You
want them to behave a certain way and
you have this red red card and when you
see red it means stop. That's all we're
doing. So green lights have strong
associate strong brands. They're
positive. Everyone loves green lights,
right? Like [laughter] it's a simple
thing just no one owns it. But green
lights are a great positive association.
It's a great brand, right? And so that's
that's the idea of what I'm what I'm
kind of diving more into. And I see it
as the ultimate cheat code for business.
It just takes a long time to do and most
people aren't patient.
You're telling me I can dodge business
problems?
I'm telling you that once you have a
brand, they become irrelevant.
You talk about deleting problems as your
favorite way of solving them?
Yes.
Uh how do you decide what's deletable
versus what's not? is I can imagine the
uh the person who really loves that
strategy doing nothing and just deleting
all problems. So how do you prioritize a
problem worth solving versus a problem
that is deletable?
Well, it's just percentage likelihood of
impact chunking all the way up to like
will this cost me number of sales like
sales velocity? Will this decrease the
lifetime value of customers? And will
this increase or decrease the likelihood
that this that whatever I'm doing right
now continues to occur. So we're trying
to value a company, right? Right? We
look at what's the sales velocity, how
many customers they sell, what's the
lifetime value of every customer,
because then you can extrapolate what
their run rate is going to be at at
scale, at max, unless we change
something. And then you divide that by
risk, which is how likely is it that
there's going to be an outside event
that's going to change this thing from
continuing to occur, this box of making
money. How likely is it that they will
it will continue to grow or at least
stay the same? And so, if I have a
problem, I have to be able to track it
back to one of those three things. And
if it doesn't really track one of those
three things or there's another problem
that has a much higher likelihood impact
in terms of it's higher likely and it
has a greater effect size then I'm going
to prioritize that. It's just that often
times if someone's like man I really
think we should change the colors on the
site. I would just say like what's the
likelihood like I have been notorious
for having ugliest [__] sites my entire
career and you can make branding make
associations and I think there's there's
an argument there but what's the
likelihood that it's going to affect how
many companies do a deal with us? It
hasn't up to this point. And so is it a
constraint of the business? No. Is it
something that I could improve?
Absolutely. There's also a hundred other
things I could improve. I could also
send more emails, which I don't do. Like
there's lots of things I could do, but
what are the few things or the one thing
that matters most, which then ladders
back up to what is the constraint of the
business?
If I look at the highest priced
competitor in my market and I one up
them and then they one up me
potentially, like is there ever a point
in which we just say like we're priced
premium enough or do we always have to
go for the top? like how do you make the
determination of premium?
There's basically four positions in the
market. You have luxury all the way at
the top which is technically a vevel
good which basic which means uh when I
increase the price demand goes up and
that's because there's an association
with the price that makes it more
valuable. So the fact that everyone
knows how expensive it is affects the
value that I get that I get from it. The
fact that everyone knows the Rolex is
100 grand the one that I'm wearing
whatever then I actually it makes the
Rolex more valuable. So it becomes a
virtuous cycle which is why LVMH is one
of the most valuable companies in the
world. Then you have premium which is
basically the above average. So it's
there you have to pair utility with the
premium. In luxury the pre the the extra
price tag is the value.
Whereas with premium like BMW is
premium. They're not luxury. They are a
little bit better at a lot of stuff and
so you pay a premium because it is a
little bit they use better materials. It
breaks less whatever right? And so then
you have your, you know, your mid tier,
your your run-of-the-mill, your
commoditized space, which sucks. And
then you have your lowcost leaders,
which they make their entire business on
how can I drive uh efficiencies in
operations at all levels of the business
so that I can be the lowest priced uh
person in the marketplace, right, and
still make a profit to to route to your
question of like when is enough enough?
The key indicator for me and most of
this like the the quote higher ticket
world, you're not luxury goods. The fact
that it's expensive is not the reason
that people want to buy it, right? It's
so it's actually technically a premium.
I'm more extreme about the price to
value discrepancy than anything else.
And a lot of people get into trouble
because they raise the price so much
that it is it's just in excess of the
value they provide. And so then they
actually create a negative experience.
Like if Chipotle were $50, people would
probably not like Chipotle. Even though
the product is really good, but at $50,
I don't know. And so the reason Chipotle
is so viral, you know what I mean? It's
like the price to value discrepancy is
so good that they tell their friends,
right? And so that's where this kind of
marriage of how can I just shortcircuit
people's brains from value perspective
which is what I what I try to do with
the books and the courses so that it
becomes viral on its own and then my
cost to acquire customers is zero and so
then everything after that is just gravy
are the four variables when you're using
this is you've got the price the value
at the top which is what they get right
the price is what they pay you've got
your cost of goods to deliver and then
you have your profit left over. And so
it's playing with those four variables
so that you can maximize the the amount
of absolute profit that the company
makes. Pricing high has become
shorthand. And where I think people get
a lot of benefit from the offers book is
that when you price higher, you
automatically weed out shitty customers.
And I think many times that is the real
reason that a lot of people's businesses
grow from that price. Now obviously
there's more profit. There's you have
excess things that you can that you can
deliver on. Um, but a lot of people
don't actually take that excess money to
create a better experience. They do a
gotcha and then they never get anything
from that customer again. And so that's
the wrong way to use it. But if I had to
think like okay what are the reasons
that you know a company might be
successful that does charge premium is
that they actually reinvest the the the
premium price into a superior product
and they are very clear about the avatar
that they go after and what the
quantitative requirements are that are
black and white that they know from
looking at their best customers their
top 20 top 5% of customers and then
saying we're only going to cater to
these customers in the future because
the likely that we can give them a great
outcome is higher and then that can
create you know you merit or earn the
premium that you have because you have
data that supports that if you are this
type of person, we can get you this type
of result.
What does the ideal experience with an
accounting firm look like to you? And I
asked because one of the things that
stuck with me um is you said you've
never done your own books. Like you've
always considered that something that
was delegatable, important to delegate.
You've also referenced bringing uh I
believe accountants in-house kind of
going back and forth between outsource
and in-house. So what does that ideal
relationship look like to you now? And
maybe what did that ideal relationship
look like when you were going through
your first, you know, seven figure and
eight figure company?
A lot of professional services should
look at Wi-Fi for inspiration. You're
like, what does that even mean? You
don't you don't want to like clap when
the Wi-Fi is working. You just notice
when it doesn't. And so you just want it
to be in the background. You just want
it to work, right? And so a lot of
companies are like that. Like there's a
lot of services that people think they
need to like over, you know, communicate
stuff on. Like I just want the
financials to be accurate and I want
them to be timely. That's it. And I want
things broken down in a way that allows
me to make business decisions. And
that's where like I think the the the
top tier of accountants transform into
fractional CFO and CFO kind of materials
where they actually help you use this
data to make informed decisions about
the business. Is there a way that I can
translate what we do into how it would
affect a business owner's life? So, I'll
tell you a little story cuz I think this
might be really re this will be really
relevant for you guys. So, one of our
portfolio companies um has had a ton of
growth three years. They went from one
location to I think we're at 38
locations now, right? All self-funded
off cash flow. All right? So, really,
really tremendous growth uh in three
years and it's compounding. So, it's
growing faster and faster. And when we
were at about 30 locations, we were
stuck at 30 locations for like two
quarters. And so I got on the phone with
the CEO and he was like, "Dude, I just I
just feel like I don't know how many
locations I can open based on cash flow
and because they had net receivables
were a little bit extended, things like
that, right?" I I like shook the screen
for a second cuz it was a Zoom call. Um
I was like, "I need you to freeze frame
this feeling you have right now." I was
like, "Okay." I was like, "Think about
this feeling you have." I was like,
"What you are feeling is finance as the
constraint of your business. You do not
have a finance function that is
operationalized enough. like you do not
like you are underdeveloped in the
finance function. You have a bookkeeper
who's not that good. As soon as he like
I could see it just clicked. I was like
that is the constraint of the business.
Until we get the finance function in,
you're going to just be operating blind.
And then once you know we have this much
cash flow, we can open two locations a
month or three locations a month. Then
you can be more aggressive with
everything else because you're confident
that you're not bankrupting the company
accidentally on your own. If I were an
accounting firm, I would try and
pinpoint the problems and relate them to
how it's going to affect growth in the
business. Like how is the constraint so
that you can talk in the language that a
business owner is going to understand?
Like they just how many I'll bet you
like if I could see everyone's hands.
How many people in your audience all the
business owner does is go to the right,
go to the bottom and say so we made more
money this month.
Great. And so I think adding that level
of strategy of like, by the way, I think
this is a little fat compared to other
companies that we're looking at. This is
a little bit under compared to other
companies we're looking at, and this
might be an area of opportunity.
Little things like that that actually
add value to the business if I were
somebody who is in charge of account.
I'd like to get this answer in less than
60 seconds because I have I know we got
to go and I want to be respectful of
your time. This has been incredibly
informative. How much of a skill should
you develop or how much should you
educate yourself before hiring for it?
So, for example, like do I need to be a
sales manager before hiring
for sales management?
What you what you hit at is one of the
hardest parts of business. You need to
make an informed decision without
context,
which is why being an entrepreneur, you
end up becoming a jack of all trades so
that you can have enough context to make
at least an informed decision. And so
I'm going to steal a playbook out of
oops wrong shoulder. There we go. Out of
Leila's book here. And I'll give you my
tactic around this, which is you want to
interview for people who are sales
managers. And you don't want to hire
anyone for a little bit, which sounds
tough, but what you want to do is you
basically want to interview for
information. Now, if you meet a a a gold
star, that's amazing, but you want to
talk to people. And if you know more
about it than they do,
they should be teaching you. And once
you talk to 10, 20 people, they're
basically like expert interviews for
what it should look like. And so then
you get a very good idea of what the
role should look like after listening to
people. And you'll get an understanding
of the level of nuance. And I'll give
you this one little tidbit that is super
powerful when it comes to judging skill.
The quality and quantity of data that
someone chooses to collect around their
particular department is almost directly
proportional to their skill. And so, for
example, I have lots of marketers who
are like, "I'm an amazing."
And I say, "Cool, tell me your metrics
are." I was like, "What's time to value,
right? What are the key activation
points? Like, what's churn?" Right?
Like, just some of these metrics. And
they're like, "Well, dude, our refund
rates really low, right?" But I'm like,
"Okay." I was like, "Well, what about
the marketing side?" They're like,
"Well, CPMs are this. This is our
click-through rates. This is our, you
know, this is our conversion on the
page. This is our percentage of
schedule. This is our percentage of
show. This is percentage open rate. This
is percentage click." Like, they go
through all this stuff. And I'm like,
"Right." So I can see very clearly that
you're a better marketer than you are at
product. And so simply getting an idea
of the quality and quantity of the data
that someone collects around their
department will get like when we hired
our director of people, it was the first
time that I had someone actually tell me
metrics I had never heard of and I was
like she's the lady, she's the gal.
My community loves you and that's how we
are here. And I literally got like 150
questions. I had to narrow it down to
five or six. It was so hard. You
mentioned something in the $100 million
offer that to hit your first 100K you
don't need a lot you just need an offer
to sell and that's exactly what we did.
Uh but right now we are hitting a
bottleneck and our biggest bottleneck is
operations and you know I want to know
how exactly you got out of gym launch
operation because we have a very similar
business model for I know service
providers
for what service providers
mostly agencies and digital consultants
with lead generation and sales. The way
we do it is with a one-on-one consulting
and in a group coaching format.
So coaching models in general tend to be
very difficult to scale because the
reason people come to you is for
expertise. In order to get other people
to provide that expertise, then you have
to create lots of experts who then
eventually walk off and start the
business on your behalf and take your
customers with them. I would say like
there's a couple different approaches.
So the first is that there's the law
firm and the McKenzie kind of consulting
model. there's a a track to become a
partner in the business and then that's
kind of the whole business structure. So
there's a way a way to share in the
profits. They do make lots of money but
the owners of those end up having to
dilute themselves out. Not that there's
anything wrong with that. You can make
lots of money doing it. But that is that
is a a version of the model. The other
way is to productize the basically get
narrower on the solution that you're
providing and productize it to the
greatest degree possible so that anyone
could do it even if they have no
knowledge of it in terms of like the
implementation of the thing. That is
more the direction that we went uh with
gym launch cuz we had a very specific we
don't even we didn't even work with all
gyms just to show how narrow we were
with it. We worked with only micro gym
owners. We have now ex expanded to
health clubs as well. The five or six
years that I was doing it before we sold
we were only micro gyms. And so just to
show like how incredibly narrow that
was. Someone had to have at least 30
members assigned lease one employee and
be running this type of model for them
to be a customer. And then if they fit
all those things, we could generate a
lot of revenue using our playbooks. I
could have somebody who had no gym
industry, no expertise whatsoever, and
still say, "Send this email, say these
words. Here's 10 recordings of people
doing this exact same thing. This is the
expected value." And so that's like from
the delivery perspective. Now, operating
the business overall comes from talent
and being able to find people who are
just as smarter, smarter than you. And
people say that, but like when you
actually meet somebody who's smarter
than you and then they admire an aspect
of what you've done so that they start
to work for you, that's where you really
start to have the magic happen.
What are some of the things that agency
owner should avoid doing if they ever
want to scale in your experience?
Okay. So, what things should an agency
owner avoid when they're trying to
scale?
Yep. Yep.
I mean, the same things that any
business owner would want to avoid when
they're scaling. Agencies tend to fall
into the, you know, they they tend to
fall into the bucket of trying to be
everything to everyone. So maintaining
the discipline to be very focused about
the problem that you're solving and who
you're solving it for. And I think that
solves 90% of the problems from a
strategic perspective for any small
business owner including an agency. The
second piece is that if you're in a
service-based business, the quality of
your talent is going to be directly
proportional to your growth because
you're you're basically selling people
fractionalized people. That's what
service businesses are, right? selling
some level of training that you're able
to give and having more efficiency than
an individual business owner would have.
Like the the classic, you know, small
business owner lead genen agency that
charges $2,000 a month. The idea is that
if they were to hire somebody full-time
to run these ads, it would cost them
$500 or $6,000 a month, but you have
copywriters, designers, and media
buyers, and page designers who all work
a fraction of their time for this one
business, and they can get it more
efficiently, and you can still do it at
good margins, right? like that's
fundamentally what service businesses
are. And so the quality of that talent
and the culture that you have at the
business to attract and keep that talent
um are the kind of the key or the
crucial pieces of the success of the
model.
You mentioned something in the book
where you mentioned the agency model
where you hire an agency to learn the
stuff and you internalize it and then
when you have stopped learning you
replace an agency but teaching agency
models uh agency businesses how to
become irreplaceable. In your
perspective, how should one go there?
Should we start with one business, then
upsell the next, and upsell the next,
and upsell the next offer?
Creating the irresistible offer isn't
necessarily about having a zillion
products. It's more about explaining and
communicating the many small things that
you have to do anyways. And so rather
than saying like, I'm going to generate
leads for you, that's like one outcome,
but there's many things that have to
happen along the way. You have to create
landing pages, you have to write copy,
you have to you have to have follow-up
sequences, you have to work the leads,
you have to have scheduling, you have
to, you know, you have to split test.
You have to make new creative. Like
there's lots of things that have to
happen in order to just get the single
result. And it's just making sure that
we're delineating those things cuz an
unbeknownsted or an ignorant uh business
owner, I say ignorant in the technical
sense, like they just don't know. Um
would have no idea what you're doing.
You're like, "Yeah, just go get me
leads." It's like, "Well, it's much
easier said than done." And if I was
doing it from an outbound perspective,
I'd be like, "Well, I have to warm up
domains. I have to, you know, spin up
different accounts. I have to split test
different email openers. I have to
split." Like, you have to explain all
the steps. And they're like, "Wow,
there's a lot more work that goes into
this. Now I can I can appropriately
value this price tag that you've
ascribed to whatever the service is." So
that's piece one. In order to be
irreplaceable, often times you'd have to
go after significantly bigger customers.
If you're an agency for Fortune 1000,
for Fortune 500 companies, it would be
so costly for them to spin up at scale
the level of talent that's required to
do like programmatic media buys across
100 different platforms in different
countries. And then the likelihood that
they want to leave or do this on their
own is significantly lower. The idea
that any service provider is going to
become truly irreplaceable like any
business can do anything on their own
and I would prefer to put myself out of
business and do it in a way that aligns
my customers with me than have a model
that I know is is basically has a timer
for obsolescence.
Not everybody works with Fortune 500
companies, right? Sometimes you many
people uh they might work with you know
small and medium businesses. They help
them. Let's say you become a marketing
agency for chiropractors in New York and
you become so good at that. In general,
people won't leave you because you're
just good at that particular service.
And the thing is, small business owners
are really tough because they're the
problem. Like they're super erratic.
They're super volatile. Their cash flow
is lumpy. They don't know where their
next paycheck's going to come from. And
to no fault of your own, they can cancel
because they just can't make payroll
that month. Look at the biggest agencies
that exist. Ogulv, you have Veayner, you
know, is up there now. Who do they
service? Massive companies. Why? because
the quality of the customers are higher
and so they know that when they sign a
contract, they actually stick with the
contract. We all know that if you have a
small business owner who signs a
12-month agreement for agency services,
he's good for three months. The biggest
model that I've seen for small business
owners from a marketing perspective um
was an agency that was running $300 a
month, $300 a month price point because
they had figured out and like there's a
key here is that like those business
owners are so price sensitive. It's not
whether you can sell them, it's whether
you can keep them on their worst month.
The price isn't based on the value that
you can deliver on the best month, but
how much you can keep on the worst month
because that's where the churn comes in.
The best model that I saw uh was doing
SEO for small business owners. And they
had completely automated every aspect of
it. Um it was basically just a playbook.
And I think it generated reviews and
maybe a couple phone calls a month, but
at a $300 a month price point, if they
got one or two phone calls a month, it
was worth it. So the bar to get over to
to ascribe value and especially on
something that I call like a nuisance
business where it's like I know I should
be maintaining my reputation. I know I
should be doing some of this stuff.
Okay, for $200 or $300 a month, I don't
feel guilty about not doing it because
this is being handled.
You're in a consulting model, right?
What happens is some clients actually do
the work and they get results and some
clients, they need a lot of follow-ups
and they need a lot of accountability
from you. How do you maintain that? Like
I'm I know I'm getting very nitty-gritty
into this, but
I'm I'm good with nitty-gritty. you talk
to basically one of the core problems of
all B2B businesses which is that you end
up taking over the person's entire
business until eventually they're like
yeah if you could just send me a check
every month and you do you run the
business that would be awesome that's
why being very disciplined about problem
definition from the services that you
provide number one and here's the one
that everyone messes up who you pick
it's not like even if you work with
chiropractors right as that as that
example you don't necessarily even want
to work with all chiropractors you look
at the customers that you have right now
that are the best customers like the top
20% or the top 10% you say okay what
characteristics do these people have
that other people don't have in my
client list? And that's both from the
soft persp the hard perspective. What
are the quantitative differences? They
have a certain size business. They're
over a certain amount of month. They
have a number of locations. They have a
certain amount of employees, number of
customers. Like you just get all that
data on them. And then also what was the
experience that they went through when
working with me? And was it different
than some of my other customers? Because
one of the things that happens often
times is that the first few customers
you get become really sticky and then
you start scaling and then you have this
front revolving door but you still have
your core business of these people that
you had in the beginning. Right? So why
is that? Because these people got more
help from you and actually got delivered
more value and then you basically tried
to scale without scaling the value that
you delivered to the original customers.
Right? And so if you're at whatever
15,000 a month and you've got five
customers and they're all like having a
great experience and you keep signing
people on, they keep leaving. It's like,
okay, well, instead of me trying to sell
five this month, why don't I just sell
one and do a great job and then not lose
them? And like, that's the key to
compounding in a service business once
you pay down the basic pay down the
inefficiencies of them not knowing what
to do yet. And being very specific about
who you serve and who you don't, like we
didn't work with personal trainers,
cycling studios, and like yoga studios
100% could use our model. We didn't work
with them because the founders tended to
be psychologically different. their
adherence was super low because they
just come from a totally different
worldview than the guys who are more
fitness, weight loss, transformation
focused, even though at the end of the
day it's just a membership with a back
room where people work out. But mindset
wise, they had a very hard time um kind
of adopting a different model even
though monetarily it totally made sense.
Which means you need to have discipline
to say no.
Dude, this is so hard to say no to this
new upcoming business because you know
it can help them but they just don't fit
your criteria.
100%. Dude, I have 13 companies. I get
1,800 a day who reach out.
Whoa.
Right. So, you have to say no.
It feels weird to like say no because a
lot of the time I get
So, we specifically
That's why most people stay poor.
They can't say no. And what happens is
you go for the short-term money and you
sacrifice the long-term money because
then you just get in this operational
rat race and then you scale up your your
costs to meet the fact that you took on
all these customers that you shouldn't
have taken on to begin with and then you
have to pay them every single month. So
then you have to keep on taking on
customers that you shouldn't have taken
on to begin with. And you get in this
vicious cycle that you can't get out of
until you downsize. You take two steps
back, five steps back. Fix your ego and
then say, "I'm only working with these
customers because ethically I know that
these are the ones that I have the
highest likelihood of success with.
Everyone else I have mediocre success."
And I can say it's their fault. I can
say it's my fault. It doesn't really
matter. All that I know is that the
likelihood that they achieve what I
think they should achieve is low.
Period. So I'm not going to sell them.
Aren't you afraid that the TAM will go
smaller? Like,
of course, you can build a niche an inch
inch wide and a mile deep. There's 30
million small businesses. You don't need
to service them. You like there's
there's 50,000 gyms that fit the model
that we have. Now, if you want to build
a $10 billion company, then yeah, you're
going to have to go after a bigger
problem. But if you want to build a 9
figure company, you can do that in
almost any industry.
So, you mentioned that when you started
out, you started with the first five
customer framework. That was awesome.
And then you just grew with referrals.
So, this question came from a fitness
consultant herself and she said that
with the competition that the fitness
market is, how do you stand out?
Honestly, it's just being authentic. 99%
of the fitness market just looks at what
other influencers are doing and say,
"I'll just I'll copy that and I'll do
stuff like that, but then you just do a
worse version of what somebody's already
doing." Zooming all the way out,
fitness, like there's no secret. Work
out more, stop eating shitty, you'll
look better over a longer time horizon.
Like, that's what it is, right? there's
going to be a subset of an audience that
is like you genuinely and they want to
get their they could get fitness
information from Alex. But if I'm a, you
know, uh, a 45-year-old Indian mother,
I'm probably not going to be her source
for fitness information. Even if I say
the identical stuff as another
45-year-old uh, Indian mother. Now, if
that 45-year-old Indian mother looks at
my fitness content and tries to make
content like mine, it's going to seem
weird. You can stick out by actually
being yourself. I know it sounds trit,
but the real like this is real. There
are so many unique aspects of someone's
life and the things they're interested
in compared to other people that if you
just lean into those differences those
those unique as the things that you're
actually into that are weird, right?
Rogan's into aliens and mushrooms and
comedy and fighting. Who would have told
him like you should be Joe Rogan? And
you're going to have people who like
some aspects and then the super fans
will be people who overlack on two or
three of the interests that you have. If
you had picked my brand, it' be like
dessert, working out, philosophy,
business, marketing, sales. They're
different. They're people who follow me
because they only like the business and
money stuff. They're people who follow
me because they only like the philosophy
stuff. They're people who follow me
because they just think the desserts and
cav stuff is funny. Like, it just
depends on what someone's going to come
in for. But if you're just you, then you
can stick with it for the long term and
that's what's going to build over time
and make you quote stand out because
there is only one version of you that's
lived your life. So, just live it
publicly.
Thanks a lot, man. I think we are at the
end of our tenure. Thank you very much
for being uh here and keep writing great
books.
I hope I hope you make so much money
from the book um and just and crush it
cuz at the end of the day there's more
problems than any one person can solve
and I hope we build businesses to solve
them. So explain to me how the franchise
works.
Yeah. So we have a lot of clients that
want to work with us and we have a lot
of closers that want to work with us and
Yan and I we just can't manage
everything ourselves. It's just too many
people. We had two options. So option
number one is place managers to replace
us, right? And then give like two to
three accounts, client accounts to each
manager so they can manage them
obviously and we can scale that way. The
problem with that was that managers only
get paid so much and they only care so
much about the business itself, right?
But when it comes to partners, they get
50% cut. They get exactly what we are
getting 50/50. The franchise thing is
interesting because I feel like you
would be able to achieve that simply
with a profit share rather than getting
investment in equity and all like the
because if if speed is the goal then you
could basically do the makeshift in
terms because like they're I'm assuming
many of them aren't planning on selling
right and so the only reason the equity
would be valuable is if they're going to
sell it sometime in the future and
buying quote more locations isn't really
a thing either. I would imagine that
just like it'd be a lot faster to just
contract, you know, basically put put
legal language around getting a profit
share in the structure, you know, the
cut that you have. Like many
[clears throat] companies have scaled
sales ors, you know what I mean? Like
insurance brokerages are just massive
sales orgs. Like real estate agents are
massive sales orgs. And so, um, they
don't necessarily have equity, you know,
I mean, equity deals because those can
just get latigious and there's lawyers
and it just takes, I'm sure you guys
have already seen this, like it just
takes more time. And I feel like there
might be like you could probably remove
a couple of the components to get the
same behavior, which is ultimately what
you're trying to do is get people who
act like owners. So that's just that's
me just shooting right off the cuff of
just looking at it.
So that's kind of why we kind of came up
with the franchise model to put like a
nice barrier there. So it's for people
who like have the experience in the
space of running an agency or like
scaling, managing high ticket sales
teams, but now you're getting like the
infrastructure that we've kind of built
over the past four years.
I mean, you can still do all that
without the without the franchise
agreement, but what problem are you
solving? Why are you not bigger?
It's a management problem
just in general. We're bringing on more
partners and doing it faster and doing
it more in a more organized way. So what
you said
it does make sense because that would
remove some friction and it would allow
us to
bring more people without risking you
know the the equity in any way. I mean
based on the model you have you guys can
own 100% of the you know like the
franchiseor but even if you if it was
just like you know the the main co you
can still have streams because you have
the software so tracking becomes the
issue but since you already have that
infrastructure built the ability to just
make sure that they get overrides. Now
if you want to put you know a $10,000
buyin or something just cuz you feel
like that increases commitment levels I
mean that's fine. Um but if you look at
uh like a Chick-fil-A for example are
you familiar with their their model?
Yeah.
Right. And so they, you know, each
location probably cost, I actually don't
know the buildout cost, but I would
imagine it costs at least a million,
probably one and a half to build a
location for Chick-fil-A and the
operators put $10,000 in. And so it's
more of a symbolic gesture than it is
like them actually, you know,
contributing capital to whatever the
thing is. But they actually don't own
equity in the business. So they get a
50/50 profit share after a royalty that
goes to Holdco. Just looking at what
they've been able to build, it seems
that that that structure works without
the equity. um in in terms of eliciting
the behavior that you guys are going
for. But from everything that you said,
even right at the beginning, you were
like, well, uh we needed something that
was more scalable because obviously we
had lots of people. There's many people
who have scaled businesses with lots of
people. And so it sounds like it's
actually a talent deficit. Like you need
to hire somebody uh or bring someone
who's a high level operator who has
scaled a salesdriven org. What's what's
revenue right now?
Uh revenue for the phone sales
organization.
Sure.
Well, every month is different around
like 4 million right now
per month. Is that GMV? So like gross
gross sales volume and then you're
getting whatever 20 25% on that.
Yeah. So you'd be looking at a at
somebody who's scaled a sales or from
you know 10 million to 100 million and
who's really op. So you'd want somebody
who looks like who's very uh very
leadership driven not a systems person.
That's not the right person. You're
looking for somebody who's who you
admire. Take this the way I mean it. You
need an adult, right? And it doesn't
that's not a function of age. Just
saying you need someone who has
experience doing this. Uh because if I
were looking at like if I were going to
go buy in right to phone sales, the
first thing I would do is hire an
operator because right now all the
things that you've described have been
people issues. So if I'm operating on
the theory of constraint, which is what
we do, I would say, okay, well then
people issues seem to be the main
problem for this business. So I'm going
to hire somebody who has experience in
this particular domain in a sales or who
has gone from X to Z.
The million-dollar question, where do
you find such people?
Well, you guys are sales guys, right? So
it's outbound. Outbound is the easiest
thing to do. Uh you could also run ads,
but the best people already have jobs.
Uh and I mean you guys know this from
from your business, right? And so it
would be it would be outreach. Outreach
is the is the easiest thing to do. Go to
LinkedIn and LinkedIn has so many tools
now like search for people who meet
these, you know, these three or four job
titles. Um probably like a like a senior
vice president or you know VP of sales.
uh sales director might be a little too
low, but probably a VP of sales uh or VP
of sales ops, something like that. Uh
like you'll have to play with the title.
It is kind of like an ad in advertising,
like you have to play to figure out when
you get the right avatars on the phone.
Uh but as soon as you get it to click,
then you're like, "Okay, these are the
types of people I want." And then you
talk to as many as you can. And the
limit test that I have for highle talent
is that I should be learning from them
on the phone call. So if I feel like I
have to teach them stuff, they're not
the right person. like if they're
teaching me things, which is also great
because then you can keep taking notes
and after 20 or 30 phone calls, you're
like, "Okay, I have a very good idea of
what excellent looks like and I can make
a more educated decision on the type of
person that I want." But that person
who's very operational should be a
people-driven leader, especially in this
type of work.
For the second part of this call, um we
would like to just bring our partners
too and uh just ask them sales question
in general and learn from you. you know
with our model do you believe that we
should utilize group selling methods
like webinars, seminars, events that way
we can compress the time frame we make
money or just focus on onetoone sales
I think it depends on on the product
that's being sold
usually products above $30,000 and
that's why we're focusing on like
onetoone model right now
I think you can do so the way that I
like building uh sales orgs is having
repeated sales materials and then
individualized so like repeated sales
materials are going to be like the VSSLs
the webinars things like that but you're
not you're closing on those webinars.
You're just qualifying and setting. And
so I want sales guys to be doing as
little information spewing as humanly
possible and really being able to start
the call with so you ready to buy and
then yes or no and then work your way so
you have 60 minutes to close rather than
okay great now like discovery like let
me talk to you about how we might be
able to help you because if you because
then sales guys get really tired of
saying the exact same pitch then they
sound like robots then they get zoned
out because they're saying something
they're not listening and so the talk
ratios get way off. Um, and so I prefer
having as much of the standardized
information sharing being done before
the call so that the closer time can be
maximized to closing rather than just sh
like teaching. But I wouldn't be trying
to pitch 30k stuff directly to a payment
page. I'd probably be pitching that to,
you know, qualifier set calls.
Yeah, that's how we're uh we're doing it
right now. But we've seen some other
people, they have like live webinars,
you know, and they have the sales guys
on the live webinars. And even though
they're selling super high ticket
offers, they try to like do that
communication/information
stage of the call like just through the
chat and then once they show level of
interest, then they get them on the
call.
Well, they're using the webinar as the
set.
Correct.
At the end of the day, there's a certain
amount of information that someone needs
to have or certain amount of like
exposure that they have to have to a
brand or a product for them to, you
know, make a buying decision. And so
that can be a long set and then a short
close. It can be a set webinar close. It
can be a long webinar then a close. Like
there's just a certain amount of
selling. You know, the runway for the
plane has to be a certain length.
Doesn't really matter where you slice
it. It just has like this is amount that
the majority of people need to have
before making a purchasing decision.
Now, some people might need less and
that's okay cuz they probably got it
beforehand from other things that
they've consumed. So, if you want to
say, okay, how do I sell? I want to
increase the likelihood that some that
the the highest percentage of people
buy, then I want to create an experience
that the highest percentage people get
all of the information that they need
prior to the closing conversation. And
so if you do a webinar as a big set
thing, I mean to me that's the same. I
mean that's all the same. Like if you
run ads to webinar ads to VSSL, then
they go to auler or you know if you have
a live call team where you have a number
that becomes the CTA and then the call
team's answering calls in real time.
Operationally, I wouldn't I wouldn't
upend my entire business because of just
a slightly different way of doing it
because I I think it's more happy to
glad. Um, as long as your throughput is
good and you're, you know, like you're
making money and you're growing right
now, I would I don't know if that would
be the constraint of the business. So,
like I think the stuff that we were
talking about earlier, like that seems
more of the constraint than kind of the
the the individual tactics, you know, in
in the example you gave.
What's your method for building trust
and credibility on a sales call um in
like the fastest way possible? like what
method, what approach do you often take
for that? Well, I mean brand matters
more than anything uh like right off the
bat and the the you know the the vast
majority of like the the hard closing
tactics and hard sales tactics have to
exist in lie of not having a brand right
it's like we have to make up all this
hard stuff uh it's kind of like in the
matrix it's like uh when you're good
enough you won't have to dodge bullets
or like you saying I can dodge bullets
it's like well when you're ready you
won't have to so like the brand is when
you're ready you won't have to but if
you don't have that which is the big
thing that you should have. But if you
don't have that, then it's the same
things that you would normally do.
You're going to try and find common
ground, be relatable, uh try like a lot
of it just comes down to how well do you
understand the avatar, right? So I think
a lot of sales teams under underprepare
by undering the avatar, the prospect,
and overeducate on the product. Like if
I understand what a 45-year-old woman's
suffering from, I can basically do the
same sales call and at the end of the
call say I can pitch therapy, I could
pitch I could pitch weight loss, I could
pitch a gym membership, I could pitch,
you know, I could pitch cleaning
services. It doesn't really matter
because if I understand the avatar
really well, I'll be able to speak to
her pains.
And what you said is true, like branding
is extremely powerful. And with the
clients that we take on for our agency,
do you recommend that we go for people
with very strong brands and take that
approach? Like that's that should always
be the focus, right? Like always go for
the brand and then from there
Yeah. Strong brand, strong product for
sure. Fair question though. Yeah,
relatability, common ground.
What's been the number one reason you've
seen show up rates increase or decrease?
Uh, it's it's 100 golden babies, no
silver bullets. So, when we when we go
into a company, we have something called
lead nurture checklist. And so, it's
just like 17 things that we do and each
one of them adds like 2 to 5%. And so,
that's how we can get something from
like 30 40% show rates to 85% show
rates. It's just doing a lot of little
things. So, I I would not look for like
the one trick. It's just like, okay, how
quickly are we responding? How how much
information do we provide them
beforehand? Are we providing a
personalized video? Like, can we give
them a gift card for showing up that
they can share a coffee with us? Like,
just how many different things can we
add in to increase the likelihood that
they show? Can we can we create an open
loop between the set and the close that
they're going to get information that
they are they got their their interest
peaked? Is there a way that we can say
that we're going to show them that we're
going to do a certain amount of work on
their behalf, then we're going to give
them the deliverable on the next call.
Right? So, they have a huge incentive.
they have huge curiosity so that they
would want to show up. Like this is
particularly true in insurance products.
So like we have an insurance company and
so like we create personalized insurance
plans. It's like okay well how do we get
more people to show up but we don't want
to send them the insurance plan that
we're going to make them before the
call. We just say we'll explain it to
you on the call.
Yeah, we implement a lot of those
tactics as well. Probably there's some
stuff that you're doing that we
currently don't have at the moment as
well. I don't know if it makes sense to
share on this call but you said there
was kind of like 17 things. Is it
possible you can maybe like send it to
us?
No. So um
Oh no. Sorry man.
All right. Honestly, it really depends
on what the business is. If we're
looking at an insurance business versus
a weight loss business, like it's more
applying a principle across. But that
being said, the big one that's that's
probably missing. Like it's usually the
big obvious thing, which is we can
always do the hundreds of little
tactics, but you're trying to dodge
bullets rather than like winning before
you start, which is like why why do so
few people trust you? Like that's the
big that's the big like I see the matrix
and then everything else becomes
irrelevant. So for acquisition.com our
show rate on calls is nearly 100%. So if
we call if we say hey we'd like to find
out more about your business today is
Tuesday our next opening is Thursday of
next week. So 9 days from now show r
still 100%. Because of brand we actually
don't need to do any of those tactics.
Now we have those tactics so that we can
help the the companies that don't have
those level of brands. But like you want
to stack the deck. You want to answer
the question why does no one trust me
and solve that. Otherwise you're always
going to deal with these issues. like do
the fundamentals for sure, but the big
the big things that'll matter most is
who you're choosing as your customers.
So Vista, you guys heard of Vista
private equity? So they're the biggest
they're the biggest software private
equity. They've got a gazillion dollars,
whatever. The way that they look at a
business is that they do a customer
analysis. And so they look for the 8020,
right? They look for the 20% of
customers that are worth more than
everyone else. And they then do a
customer analysis and say, "What do
these 20% have that the other 80%
don't?" And then they exclusively look
for customers that are that 20%. and
then they say no to everyone else. And
so then what happens is if the sales
velocity remains unchanged, they 5x the
business. So sometimes you'll make more
money just by saying no so you can have
the capacity to say yes to the few guys
that matter more. And if you're not
getting more of those people than
solving that problem rather than saying
like how do I keep getting how do I how
do I polish a turd instead of going from
that perspective just saying like maybe
I just should not try to polish turds
because it's still a turd, right? And
like how do I get the people who are
much better companies to be attracted to
my business? And if you have a customer
list that people aspire to be like, then
you'll get more and more people like
that's where that's like kind of the
branding side for you guys, which is how
can I associate with better quality
brands so that other better quality
brands realize that what we do is legit.
You can try and optimize the [__] out of
something, but like usually it's the big
obvious stuff and we don't look at the
big obvious stuff because they're
actually harder problems to solve and
they take longer, but it's where the
most value is unlocked. What's the ideal
frequency and the topics of coaching
calls that would increase the overall
performance of setters and closers?
So I would say it's less about the
topics of the calls and more about what
you're training repeatedly and what
you're rewarding. So sales is one of
those really interesting businesses or
like you know departments that you can
see very clearly like you guys have
probably seen different sales teams and
they have very different cultures and so
it' be like what are the cultures that
create the highest performance. In our
experience, you know, you can go on all
on either extreme. You can have a very
punishment driven culture, which is very
individualistic, or you can have a very
team-driven culture, which is typically
reward based. What you want to reward is
adherence to the script, not closing.
Like, that's a huge shift for most sales
teams. If you reward adherence to the
script, then what happens is you get
everyone to follow the script. Now, if
they aren't closing, then you need to
change the script. But it's much easier
to change the script once you've taught
adherence than it is to have a bunch of
lone wolves who do anything they can to
close the deal, which then impacts your
brand. So, like a really simple, you
know, tactic we did at one of our chains
was we just said, "Cool, we'll give them
five bucks if they follow the script."
Whether they close the Now, mind you,
the the tickets are smaller, right? It's
just higher higher volume. We'll give
them five bucks if they follow the
script. And if they close or they don't
close, they get paid either way. You
know what's interesting? The thing
they're most curious about when they
send their managers is do I get the five
bucks for the adherence, even though
they make three times more on the close.
So, we still we still give them benefits
for closing, but they want to know
whether they got the approval of the
manager because the $5 actually matters
less than the approval from the manager
saying you did a good job. The $5 is
more of a token.
That makes a lot of sense.
And if you can imagine, because you
everybody here has sold before, if you
got on a call and you knew that you
could get paid no matter what just for
following the process, it takes some of
the pressure off. Like, think about like
you hopped in the car like I'm just
going to make sure that I get my bone no
matter what on on the adherence. But
guess what happens when everybody
adheres to the script? You [__] close
more.
There you go. Because sales is one of
the biggest issues where you have false
positives, where someone goes rogue and
then closes and basically gets
reinforced for doing the wrong thing and
then they start doing the thing that
they did that one time that worked and
then it doesn't work over and over
again. So they change the behavior. They
learn the wrong thing,
right?
And so then you have to course correct,
right? That's why sales like it's all
about adherence and then then we can be
really strategic about really making
sure the script is beautiful and crisp
and concise. Uh, and we just and we just
drill the team on adherence.
The big topic I want to address is how
to sell emerging tech.
You don't sell emerging tech. You it's
it's selling the plane flight versus the
vacation. If I could tell you that your
financials would be absolutely accurate
and updated in real time, would you want
that? How much would you be willing to
pay compared to what you currently pay?
A lot more. Great. What if I said I
could do it for less than what you're
currently paying? Are you interested?
Great. This is what I need. The fact
that I'm using AI is irrelevant.
You just sell the outcome and then you
not really cares. AI is great for
YouTube clickbait, but for for sales
it's irrelevant.
That was like one of the main talking to
get across.
What else you want to do for the next
16? [laughter]
You must be getting a ton of businesses
potentially some a lot of AI businesses
that are coming across your desk right
now at acquisition.com. What are the
things that's making sort of jumping out
at you and what are the sort of
commonalities between things that make
you really go, "Oh, wow. That that seems
to have some kind of staying power." Uh
the vast majority of AI businesses that
I look at are are are dog [__] And so
they're either they're not real AI,
which is 99% of them. They're basically
just built on chatbt, which is fine.
There's nothing wrong with that. But I'm
just like, let's not claim that we're
creating AGI. On the other hand, it's
it's people who have no business acumen.
And so they're like, it's totally
different. Like the the normal laws of
business don't apply. It's like they
have always applied and they will always
apply because they're just how business
works, right? Those are the the vast
majority of people that I see in that. I
do think that AI implementation for Main
Street is an enormous opportunity. So
AIing, if you will, and I I don't think
I think your first conclusion is right,
which is being the custom guy is tough.
You know what I mean? It's just it's
it's all things to all people, which is
nothing to no one. If I'm talking to the
audience now, if you guys want to get
into this world, what you want to do is
look at an industry or an avatar that
you understand well. And so one of the
things that like Y Combinator and some
of these great like you know legendary
investors look at is how much time a
founder has suffered and lived through a
problem. I can talk about breathing cuz
I've had two nose surgeries. I've been
falling asleep on my hand since I was in
eighth grade so that I could breathe. So
like I've lived with the problem for a
long time and I've tried many different
types of solutions. So I have tons of
industry knowledge if I were to start a
company like that. If you have a job
right now or have had any type of job,
you've worked in a business. That's a
great baseline of background knowledge
that's difficult to just jump. Like if
even if you were a server at a
restaurant for two years, you still will
probably know more about restaurants
than 99% of people who aren't in the
restaurant industry. Like I don't know
anything about how restaurants work cuz
I've just never really worked in one.
You could probably be aware of because
you now also have this understanding of
what AI can do to think, okay, there's a
hundred problems in a restaurant. Is
there one very specific problem that I
can solve well and is very similar
between restaurants? Because as soon as
you get the point A to point B, you can
create the clear value prop and you can
message around that. Getting extremely
specific, which is I think what you were
saying that you give the advice to is
super smart and it makes the problem set
really narrow to solve. So you can
become an expert that's a an inch wide
and a mile deep.
The ex exact same thing.
The reason that most people don't do
that when they're starting out is
because you don't have enough demand.
You have so few leads that come to you
that you're like, "Well, I I mean, [__]
I need to pay rent this month and I only
got four leads this month and all four
are completely different, but I need the
money." And so, I get it. Redeploy that
cash into getting really concentrated on
your marketing, which is what offers and
leads is all about so that you can find
that specific avatar that you can over
and over again repeat, which is also why
referrals are so strong because if you
do a good job, they will send you other
people just like them.
The the question is is yes, I can pick a
niche to do this AI automation. I can
build AI solutions and sort of targeted
one but what is the opportunity that I
should target within the niche and that
comes down to either a as you said
industry experience that you already
have or sort of be what we've said is
finding some sort of partner within the
industry. So we say you can either try
to pay them for their time as a
consultant or you can just message
enough people and say hey look I'm
looking to bring these kind of solutions
to the industry would you be willing and
working working on this with me I need a
little bit of your specific knowledge
but in exchange I'll create this thing
and you can refer you can basically have
first dibs on sharing it to your network
and you can make some money that way. So
yeah I definitely wouldn't do it as a
consulting relationship. the the thing
that you're going to be selling is the
product. And so having a consultant
who's the one who's in charge of the
primary value that you're driving is not
a good idea. And so you'd want somebody
who's long-term incentivized to
continually improve the product,
continue to innovate the product, see
the things that are coming around the
corner to keep it up to date, make it
better, make it stronger, etc. It really
just comes down to how to have a normal
business partnership. So all the normal
rules of business apply, and this person
has some specific knowledge you don't
have, and you should ideally have
specific knowledge they don't have. They
should be asking the question like why
do I partner with the people in your
community if I'm an AI developer? Right?
If you're trying to figure out which of
the problems to solve in an industry,
it's just value created times ease of
implementation. That's the equation.
Which if you chunk it up, it's number of
potential customers times gross profit
per customer. If I have six different
problems I could potentially solve,
which one has way more people who have
it? Which one's easier to do? Which one
unlocks the most value? One thing that
we're starting to see as as us ourselves
actually trying to build one of these
these AI automation agencies now AI
development company as well is that by
building a a development team that is
capable what is is your take and your
experience with how important that
development resource is. I mean I'm sure
with your event you must know working
with developers can be a complete plan
but having them inhouse and having a
really good team to rely on as you shoot
for those big opportunities can be key.
I mean what's your experience been like
this and how important do you think that
development resource is when you're
going for those bigger plays?
Very
very [laughter] okay. I mean, we were
thinking the same thing. So, I was glad
to know you agree on that.
It's the product. Like, if you're in a
service business, the quality of the
people that you use to provide the
service is the product. And so, those
people usually want to be compensated
well because if they are really good,
then the places that they're coming from
will want to pay more to keep them. And
so, you have to give them a great place
to work and a financial incentive or
some upside that they get exposed to
that they wouldn't otherwise. Like you
want them to feel like owners and the
best way to do that is for them to
actually be owners. If you're trying to
get on the cutting edge of technology,
then actually having the people who are
good at that is the business.
Well, it is a great resource to have a
really killer marketing team under your
belt. But the the development side of
things, I I tend to find at least in our
experience has been a harder thing for
us to to create
because you don't know it. Like it's
easier for you to do the marketing stuff
because you're good at it. So you know
if someone's full of [__] on the
interview, you just don't know if
anyone's full of [__] on the interview
because you have no context. The most
important hire, which is why I say this,
is you need a technical co-founder. You
need somebody who has a real stake in
making sure that the people who are
coming in are actually good. Not that
you're checking a box and saying, "Hey,
I have 14 people on my development
team." Anybody in the in the true
high-tech world knows that one amazing
developer is more valuable than 100 B
developers. This is the hardest part of
business is hiring people who are really
good at something without knowing the
in-depth knowledge. And that's where
like leveraging somebody who might not
want to work for you that you do think
is brilliant to at least interview or
double check on how good they are um is
really valuable. That's where like
building a network becomes important and
getting even some tests like of aptitude
for them to take so that you can at
least get some sort of baseline. But
it's all going to be about how skilled
that person is. Cuz ideally if they were
as good as you are at marketing then you
guys would probably have a really
successful business. we've been
fortunate enough to to find that find
that magical sort of technical
co-founder. So, um we're starting to get
in really well compensated both getting
in equity as well. So, we are off to the
races and that's completely changed our
business. I can't even stress for for
anyone of you in here that that key hire
is just a complete game. I'm sure you've
had it, Alex, in your businesses where
you've just found that right person and
it just completely changes things.
All right. Appreciate you guys. Thank
you and appreciate the community. Thank
you guys for showing up. Hopefully the
book serves you guys well.
How do you feel like in general? Do you
think like the you think you brought as
much value as you promised?
I hope so. I try to answer the questions
to the best of my ability
and provide value to the humans.